today marks the close of day four of the
Manafort trial joining us now live from
Washington with the latest on that and
more is Ellison Barber Ellison so for
months president Trump's legal team has
gone back and forth on whether or not
the president will sit down for an
interview with Special Counsel Robert
Muller one thing at issue for the
president's legal team are the questions
investigators plan to ask him the
president's personal attorney sent a
letter to Muller asking about the scope
and format of an interview sources tell
Fox News the special counsel has now
responded to that letter and that Muller
agreed to have some questions answered
in writing their new reports tonight the
special counsel team spoke with a woman
known as the Manhattan Madame on
Wednesday her name is Kristen Davis she
ran a high-end prostitution ring in New
York City you might know her name
because it came up during the Eliot
Spitzer scandal we reached out to the
special counsel about this they declined
to comment we're working on trying to
figure out more on this in general but
according to reports investigators are
interested in Davis's ties to Trump ally
Roger stone all of this is the
president's former campaign chairman
Paul Manafort finishes his fourth day
before a federal judge in Virginia mana
force accountant testified with immunity
this afternoon and she said she
falsified documents to help mana for
secure a loan and also classified income
as a loan which would lower mana Forte's
taxes mana fort is facing charges
related to financial fraud he denies any
wrongdoing mana fort was of course
indicted by special counsel robert
muller but the things we usually think
of when we talk about the special
counsel Russia President Trump those
really haven't been topics at the trial
but there's certainly judge elephants in
the room thanks so much